popping Rockstars it's me Mt and King
the Conqueror did not die at the end of
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania but
instead became one of the biggest
threats to the entire Marvel Multiverse
as a whole just like he did in the
comics because although King's body as
he knew it was for sure destroyed after
wasp pushed him into his unstable
Quantum energy core Kang's exposure to
this combination of energies made him
into something more I believe this is a
little something called a Quantum
temporal way which is exactly what
happened to the Kang variant immortus in
the time Quake storyline from the 1992
what if comics in that series The
immortus Kang variant absorbs enough
energy from Nexus beings and becomes a
non-corporeal Quantum wave King that
threatened to rearrange the Multiverse
as he saw fit and I think the MCU will
adapt this by making Quantum India Kang
living Quantum energy with the power to
make infinite duplicates of himself like
Scott did in the movie because if he's
going to fight the Council of kings and
invade the timelines he's going to need
an army of Kings himself and who better
to trust than an exact copy of himself